flashes precious action meaty mouthful
golem was really the first CG character
that we were hoping to put on screen
that had to believably act in a human
fashion with other actors now I don't
want any trouble
you understand just show me the way to
get out of here and I'll be on my way
nurse Lee versus Robbie's so first order
shut up Prince Ivan I wasn't talking to
you
one of the very first breakthroughs for
Golem was casting Andy Serkis to play
the voice of Gollum have any frogs
Andy's physical presence onset became an
important part of how Gollum was
developed and so what we wanted to do
was to take all that physicality and
find a way to capture that and bring it
to the digital character Gollum hence
the idea of performance capture my kuchi
kuchi
why was your baby without me well I it
was me I survived because of me ten
years later when we had to bring Gollum
back for The Hobbit we had had in the
meantime experience working with lots of
other characters so we were able to
develop now proper muscle systems proper
skeletal systems proper facial
expressions a lot of research into the
look of how light is transported in the
eyes and the skin and the hair to really
get that detail working properly we
realized that what we really have to do
is study the way muscles really work in
the human body how they attach to all
the joints how bundles of muscle fibers
are constantly firing off in opposition
to each other and in support of each
other when a person is moving and
therefore we
to see that when a character was moving
and so we've developed a new system that
we call tissue which allows us to really
simulate all of the muscles and movement
that's happening from the skeleton
outward to the skin and with a character
like Gollum where he has basically very
little clothing on you can see all of
that movement now so if you really look
you can perceive the ribs and the
muscles all moving under the skin as it
performs Gollum as a CG character needed
to have this believability this
fleshiness that you see when you look at
humans either in person or on screen so
I encountered a technique called
subsurface scattering that I thought was
really the basis of what we needed to
solve to get believable looking
characters
for the hobbit we were able to bring out
a new generation of the subsurface
scattering technique that if you look
closely in the film you can really now
see that the pores the wrinkles the fine
skin creasing everything that happens in
the skin at a detailed level when you're
watching Gollum perform and where you
really notice all these things come
together in a character like Gollum
especially is in the eyes because the
eyes are just these great spheres that
absorb all the light to come into them I
was really happy with what we saw of
Gollum in The Hobbit I mean I thought
he's a great character it was always
compelling it was always interesting and
Gollum as a character I still find very
engaging I just enjoy watching him stop
yes
Charles
you